getting it done and also getting a very
fine score john when you came into this
tournament you knew
you had the target on your back it turns
out you weren't such an easy out and not
a bad result overall yeah i mean when i
came in i knew everyone would be gunning
for me in a way and i told myself i
wouldn't like set a certain goal like i
have to score x amount of points to be
satisfied i just thought i would play
every game and
learn from the experience and do the
best i can and yeah minus one as a final
score i think mathematically is pretty
far above what i'm expected so yeah i'm
definitely happy yeah i think if you got
minus three or four we think that's
about the range or minus one
there are a lot of good players in this
tournament that are not going to make
that score including your opponent who
you defeated today
yeah um i don't know i mean jeffrey had
an
uh bizarre tournament because he started
with a few losses in a row but then
he won a good game against shankland and
he seemed to be back to his normal form
so i wasn't really thinking about that
going into the game i was just trying to
play my best
this game he
played a move c5 that really tested his
position and then compounded it with
knight f4 you must have had your eyes
just lighting up when you saw that you
could attack his king yeah i didn't
expect c5 i thought he would play d5
there um
but
yeah if we may take a look sure yeah so
i thought he would play d5 and i i don't
know uh e594 for example
um
even if you have to give up a pawn for
the bishops yeah i i thought that um he
has compensation there i could play
knight c3 instead maybe
um but then he takes and plays c5 maybe
i don't know i wasn't sure i i didn't
think it was a big deal i didn't expect
c5 at all
and then you you got an attack going
there is one moment he had to defend
however
right after
this we saw knight
we saw knight h5 was the best move
according to the engine but then you got
an attack rolling with g6 with a knight
f4
here
and then queen h4 the engine gives
knight c3 is only equal the knight d2
was the stronger move
to defe as you played it with uh knight
to c3 he did have knight g5 disrupting
your attack yeah
as always the move i was happy with
knight c3 is not the right one
uh
yeah honestly i didn't even consider an
ig5
to be perfectly honest but the point is
like if i take on h6 here
i was sort of considering that and if
like he takes on b3 now then knight c3
must be just completely winning
looks like it's similar in that
variation yes yes the problem is instead
of taking on b3 i was concerned about
bishop takes d4 i think
maybe i still have something good here
but
my idea was knight c3 is useful for me
in in all lines i think so
i thought i would play it first but yeah
i didn't see knight g5 at all in the end
you had just a blast of a position as
you
completely cracked his position with d5
and went on to win any shades of
the us junior that you defeated him to
actually get into this tournament no
because i mean this was like a real game
and it wasn't like
uh some random time scramble i mean
obviously to win a classical game is a
lot more important so yeah i'm
definitely happy with this lessons
learned from this tournament
um
don't fall into a 2800s prep
by repeating the same thing you played
in round one
like i'm not sure
i'm not sure what i was thinking against
fabi like
something like he didn't prepare for me
or something i i don't know what was
going through my mind but yeah i mean i
only lost to 2700s in this tournament
the
the games i lost were i mean not very
good but
yeah overall i have a lot to take away
from this and
hopefully i can qualify again at some
point that would be really cool that
would indeed be cool congratulations on
a good result and see you next time
thanks
congratulations indeed john very very
nice result
what